avec hélène frade bien sûr bonjour
hélène jourda niafs à la une de la
presse cette décision l'algérie d'abord
de suspendre un traité de coopération
avec l'espagne après le revirement de 2
madrid sur le dossier du sahara
occidental d'après le journal officiel
algérien el moudjahid à alger a réagi
aux choix du gouvernement espagnol
d'apporter son soutien au projet
d'autonomie marocain pour le sahara
occidental
un revirement
injustifiable pour le gouvernement
algérien qui soutient à lui le
mouvements indépendantistes du front
polisario estime que la nouvelle
position de madrid vis-à-vis de son
ancienne colonie s'inscrit en violation
de la légalité internationale je cite
l'algérie rompt avec l'espagne en raison
des arguments fallacieux de pedro
sanchez le quotidien de droite espagnol
el mundo est également très critique
vis-à-vis de la décision du premier
ministre socialistes qui l'accusent
d'avoir cédé aux aspirations
annexionnistes du maroc sur le sahara
occidental tournant ainsi le dos à
l'engagement historique de madrid en
faveur du droit du peuple sahraoui à
décider de son avenir par un référendum
d'autodétermination
conformément aux résolutions des nations
unies l'algérie aux journalistes ihsan
al qadhi a été condamné mardi à six mois
de prison ferme le monde présente cette
condamnation du directeur de radio m
comme une nouvelle manifestation de la
répression qui s'est abattue sur les
militants du irak le mouvement de
révolte née en 2019 selon le site
spécialisé algerian a dit anis 2 172
détenus d'opinion se trouve actuellement
dans les prisons algériennes à la une
également la disparition qu'on continue
à suivre depuis dimanche un journaliste
britannique et d'un spécialiste des
peuples autochtones dans une région
reculée de l'amazonie brésilienne la
disparition de john phillips et de blood
près d'1 kg est beaucoup de gardienne
qui presse le gouvernement brésilien
d'intensifier ses recherches journal
britannique dénonce l'attitude de
jaillir ball sonoro qui a semblé blâmer
les deux hommes pour leur propre
disparition favreau franchement deux
personnes sur un seul bateau dans une
région totalement sauvage c'est une
aventure qu'on ne recommande à personne
tout peut arriver
a déclaré le président brésilien
vilipendé par le quotidien pour avoir
affaibli les protections
environnementales et les droits fonciers
des populations autochtones et d'avoir
bafoué les droits de l'homme et les
l'état de droit depuis son arrivée au
pouvoir en 2010 mais un mois à présent
de la décision de la justice française
d'ouvrir une enquête sur sur le yacht
d'un oligarque russe tout cela pourrait
aboutir la confiscation définitive de ce
bateau mais la france se dirige t elle
vers la première saisie judiciaire d'un
bien d'un oligarque russe sous le coup
de sanctions européennes à cause de la
guerre en ukraine d'après le monde le
super yacht à moi les vélos amour
véritable propriété du milliardaire igor
setchine serait temps au cal le plus
près d'être confisquée définitivement
par la justice une première qui
permettrait de faire rentrer des
dizaines de millions d'euros dans les
caisses de l'état français qui s'est
contenté jusqu'à présent de geler les
biens des personnalités russes
sanctionner le washington post de son
côté annonce une victoire pour les
etats-unis après la décision mardi de la
cour suprême des îles fidji d'autoriser
les autorités américaines à saisir un
autre yacht appartenant appartenant
également à neully gars que proclame la
souleimane km 9 valeur estimée de
l'amadea damien gigantesque super yachts
de 106 mètres avec piscine jacuzzi
héliport et jardins diversion le pont
plus de 300 millions de dollars mais
encore on parle pas des frais
d'entretien elles aussi elles valent
extrêmement cher des équipes des
antiquités égyptiennes une valeur
exceptionnelle aurait été l'objet d'un
vaste trafic international
tout ça au bénéfice du louvre d'abu
dhabi mais selon une enquête de
libération lagence france muséums une
structure qui a été créé en 2007 et dont
la mission consistait à sélectionner des
heures à s'assurer de leur origine
légale et à négocier les prix pour le
compte du louvre d'abu dhabi or est
acquis des pièces d'égyptiennes avec de
faux documents d'après libé une partie
de ses oeuvres provenant notamment de
pillage harquet parquet logique la
presse française qui revient aussi ce
matin sur la révolte des villes
touristiques contre le système rbi une
hausse des prix pénurie de logements
d'après le figaro la multiplication des
locations de courte durée entraîne des
difficultés à se loger pour les
habitants de ces villes dont certains se
mobilisent en prenant des mesures
coercitives comme ici à bayonne c'est au
pays basque où les élus ont voté une
réglementation qui vise directement les
locations de type airbnb à texte qui a
finalement été suspendue par un tribunal
administratif les inconvénients et
méfaits du tourisme de masse dont il est
aussi question damien dans le guardian
qui rapporte qu'une touriste américaine
n'a rien trouvé de mieux que de dévaler
en scooter les escaliers de la place
d'espagne à rome occasionnant près de
25000 euros de dégâts mais encaisseront
démarche mais on se quitte pas là dessus
il n'a pas question de vous laisser
filer et damien sans mentionner la
disparue la disparition j'en perds mon
latin d'un monument de la télé sud
coréenne le présentateur son gré qui
anime est un télé-crochet depuis
1988 vous étiez tout gamin est décédé
hier à séoul à l'âge de 95 ans st-gall
et avait récemment intégré le livre des
records en tant que présentateur en
activité le plus âgé du monde
record à battre damiri gorge enfin on
imagine bien sûr paris ait à 96 ans
lorsque vous avez des gens déjà pas très
bien merci beaucoup à l'aise pour cette
revue de presse on passa à l'info échos